und ich bin mir ganz sicher viele kleine
zuschauer am fernseher fragen sich
inzwischen wo kommen diese ganzen
wunderbaren vollpfosten eigentlich her
schöne geschichte die werden von den
kleinen weihnachtswichtel am nordpol
gebastelt genauer gesagt und ulrich von
heesen und gernot hassknecht katastrophe
seitens der nordpol gekauft hat ist das
nur schufterei hier stimmt wie lange
dauert unsere schicht bis es hell wird
wir sind am nordpol hier wird im winter
nie l genau kapitalismus guck mal hier
der vollpfosten für den saudischen
kronprinzen mit knochensäge zum
ausklappen
man weiß ja nie war ein bruch dieser
verbrecher kritische journalisten
umbringen so einer gehört ging der
national gerechnet
ich sag mal beim g20 gipfel
da der putin begrüßt wie so ein schulhof
kumpel in der raucherecke
wir müssen heute wieder zur stückl haft
moderne diktatoren nehmen für sowas
novikov fresse da kommt die amazon
überwachungsdrohne
[Musik]
scheiß verein hätte ich auch bei herren
muss bleiben können so was haben wir
denn hier
den pfosten für ursula von der leyen
wo ist er denn die lieferung verzögert
sich um fünf jahre
dafür wird er aber zehnmal so teuer so
wie alles bei der bundeswehr
ursula von der leyen kriegt den pfosten
weil sie ihrem ministerium 2018 komplett
an beraterfirmen wie mckinsey fertigt
hat und sie hat uns im bundestag das
zitat des jahres geschenkt und
entscheidend für die männer und frauen
ist was hinten raus kommt und das ist
ein neuer schwerer transporthubschrauber
schenkt schmerz dass das ist der
vollpfosten in der lam pollen edition
verliehen an den deutschen wolf für das
comeback des jahres mindestens 73 rudel
laufen wieder durch deutschland und
verbreiten angst und schrecken also also
es ist noch kein einziger mensch
verletzt worden aber das heißt ja nicht
dass man keine panik machen darf wir
brauchen hilfe weil sie der natur dienen
aber die wölfe die dummes zeug tun
sie gehören konsequent erschossen das
wolfsrudel schlägt auch inmitten der
häuser erbarmungslos zu und das blut der
weidetiere sprit bis an die häuserwände
in niedersachsen geben da warten die
kinder auf dem schulweg knietief durch
schaafs eingeweide leben halt töten oder
getötet werden wie beim black friday
gültig was ist schon wieder ostern ein
der geht nicht an den osterhasen der
geht an den ost hasen für dieses
erschütternde video aus chemnitz das
beweist der rechte mann steht unter der
fuchtel der rechten frau
so wächst hier
du bleibst hier also wollte doch nur
ausländer klatschen
da haben wir gar nichts mehr ach so das
paket geht in die ddr dann packe ich
doch noch in fünf kaffee und papa mal
sind es heute bei betriebsrat können wir
bei der arbeit wenigstens ein bisschen
musik hören
[Musik]